[Music]
is one camera in particular I remember
my dad went to his father a couple times
and was like the [__] needs to stop
and the dad was like I try to talk to
him and this and then he kept getting
worse and worse and
one day my dad found him hanging out in
a parking lot how old was the kid at the
time 17 at the time recorded the story
because my dad goes you're 17 and he's
like so what my dad goes okay well if I
wait a year I'll get in a lot less
trouble someday I have this bad feeling
I'm gonna be driving home and there's
gonna be an accident
and if there is
I just have this terrible feeling that
if I ever hit you with a car it's gonna
I'm gonna hit you so [__] hard it
takes them weeks to find your body in
the woods he told that to like a
teenager
like threatened I'm scared
the Honeydew with Ryan sickler
[Music]